ANTHONY MACKIE
With the Dora Milaje,
I didn't know what to expect.
SEBASTIAN STAN
There's something magical about it all.
KARI SKOGLAND
The Wakandans are back
and they brought
so much to the party.
FLORENCE KASUMBA
When we show up,
you don't know
how many are around.
[Laughing]
JOHN WALKER
Put down the pointy sticks
and we can talk this through.
ANTHONY MACKIE
There's a confidence...
...and all of us
get out of the way.
SEBASTIAN STAN
Yeah!
WYATT RUSSELL
You can only do so much!
SAM WILSON
You should do something.
KARI SKOGLAND
He realizes how vulnerable he is.
Is he going to take
the super soldier serum?
WYATT RUSSELL
That decision...
...is crushing.
SAM WILSON
We're going to need all hands on deck
for whatever's coming next.
FLORENCE KASUMBA
I'm so excited to see the outcome.
KARI SKOGLAND
We are not spoiling anything.
[Laughing]
BARON ZEMO
I'm sure it will all come to
an agreeable conclusion.